dr. Jordan Pearson good morning good
morning thank you so much for coming in
you're developing this enormous power
and reach is it the heavy burden for it
well it it's heavy and light at the same
time you know it's it's constant I don't
know what I'm doing day-to-day until
that day I have people managing my
schedule and I'm busy enough so that I
pretty much attend to the next thing but
the responsibility of getting into all
these heads mm-hmm and you are
influencing people's signa me aren't you
well I guess I take solace in the fact
that so many thousands of people now
have written to me and also talked to me
to say that things are better for them
because they've been trying to do some
of the things that I suggest in my
lectures and so it is a heavy
responsibility when when you have
influence of that sort but it lightens
it when you also have evidence
suggesting that it seems to be doing
people a lot of good your changing laws
that seems to be the case
in Worcester well I would say there were
six people in the audience last night I
was talking in Melbourne I would say
there were six maybe there were more but
there were at least six so half a dozen
and they were young men who told me that
that that's that's what they said yeah
how do you feel about that breaks me up
what oh it's a very positive thing
you've done what what do you mean it
breaks you up well it's sad that there
are so many people in that state of
crisis you know and they don't need that
much encouragement that's the thing so
it's sad that it only takes that much
encouragement to make that much
difference there's a lot of lost people
in the world so it's a good thing to be
able to help that it's overwhelming
what can tell that you're very emotional
about it yeah well it's really something
you know what time I hadn't thought much
about what had happened last night but
you know probably 500 people lined up
after the talk and most of them say the
same thing you know about it
quarter of them say look you're putting
into words things I already knew I
always knew but I didn't know how to say
just like oh that's what archetypal
stories do and and I guess that's what
articulate people do you know so that's
a good thing but then the other 3/4 of
them say some variant of of you know my
life has been turned around they say I
was addicted or I was drinking too much
or I wasn't moving ahead my relationship
with my girlfriend I wasn't getting
along with my family I didn't have any
direction in life I was nihilistic or
hopeless or anxious or any number of
variants of those and I've been trying
to put into practice what you've been
talking about in your YouTube lectures
and podcasts and and it's really helped
my turn my life around
thank you it's like yeah do something
you feel fragile about that well no I
wouldn't say exactly that um I seem to
be able to handle this it's been going
on a long time now it's it's been 18
months and I would say in many ways now
it's better than it was because at the
beginning especially when I got when I
put my hat in the political ring let's
say because I felt that the Canadian
politicians had overstepped their
boundaries mm-hmm
you know my job was threatened and quite
severely and I thought I might lose my
clinical license as well and things were
up in the air in a big way yeah was my
refusal when I stated refusal to abide
by the by the requirement that that I
modified my language in a certain manner
that I felt was you know appropriate
oh I felt it was inappropriate of the
government to demand that I modify my
language the government has no right to
intrude on people's lives to that degree
it's very very dangerous when that
happens and so anyways there was I've
been in one scandal after another in
Canada like seriously like non-stop for
18 months the last one just two days ago
I was at Queen's University in Kingston
and there was a big demonstration there
was a very eerie occurrence they
arrested a woman who was carrying a
garage for God's sake you know and fraud
that was not the Queen's University
thing was not good we were in a hall it
was kind of like a church this that's
Hall it's what it looked like it was
lined with stained glass windows and
probably 20 of them and there was a
protester had climbed up in the window
well of all 20 windows probably five or
six feet off the ground and there were
seven feet high these windows and they
were pounding on them and forcefully
forcefully enough in one case to break
the window and so there was 900 of us
inside and it was we were surrounded by
this group that were pounding on the
windows and yelling pounding on the
doors and it was and you know you could
see against the stained glass you could
see these shadowy forms pounding away
and it was it was very eerie no one and
no one in that Hall will ever forget
that experience why why were they trying
to get in why the garage why the it
sounds like height is it height some of
it was hate for sure what are the
hedging because they because of who they
imagine I might be I guess that's part
of it you know it's it's it's easy to
hate someone who's been cricketer dand
so but there's more to it than that I
have been very forceful let's say and my
criticisms of the radical left not only
in Canada but in the West in general not
critical enough in my estimation so I
hold no stock whatsoever for the radical
leftist I'm absolutely appalled that
they're the force they are in the
universities and I do believe that in
many ways the universities have done
more harm in society than good over the
last 20 years and I say that you know
with a fair bit of regret because I've
been obviously associated with
universities since 1993 it's a really I
sometimes enjoy dealing with the radical
lift in the university so I think you're
gonna grow up you're going to get
through this and I enjoy the the
challenge and the drama and the yeah
it's a challenge of you saying you're
wrong well I'm right and I know I'm
right because I'm 20 and I know
everything it's not the students so much
I'm concerned about stuff is it
oh yeah it's the abstract and the
administrators and no it's not the
students I mean look I've been protested
against I watched the protesters and
most of the time the vast majority of
them are young people whose whose desire
to have a positive influence in the
world
is channeled into this particular
political expression at the moment but
so many of them are manipulated by the
faculty members hmm and there's no
excuse for that and what they're doing
is is far more dangerous than it looks
why do young men need you well first of
all you know it's not I would say it's
not just young men part of that's an
artifact of the fact that most of the
people who watch YouTube are young men
but but I won't evade the question I
mean because see to some degree
maturation among men is a voluntary
process it's not so voluntary for women
they have to grow up fast they have a
lot of things to do before they hit 30
yeah with men it can it can take longer
and they need a call to adventure let's
say and they need a call to
responsibility and they need to be they
need to to be initiated into
responsibility and to have a case made
for its utility and so I'm saying look
it's better to be adult than to be a
child it's better it's better to be in
control of your own destiny there's a
place for you in the world the world
would be lesser if you don't take your
place in it that you have a
responsibility to bear to sort out your
education to straighten out your life
and to become who you are
grow the hell up don't grow up and and
grandfer for reasons that are positive
for you positive for your family
positive for everyone so is but is this
generation lost they desperate they're
clinging to what you're saying and doing
in a desperate I'm not criticizing what
you're saying I'm doing but they need it
they need it desperately why why they
think I think that I think that every
generation needs a message that that
that supports maturation and and
responsibility I think that we've done a
bad job as a culture of putting that
message forward so to me since the
mid-1960s our young people have been fed
a never ending diet of rights and
impulsive freedoms something like that
and that leaves a hole because most of
the meaning that people people manage in
their lives and so that would be the
meaning that you can offset against the
tragedy of life that comes from adopting
responsibility and carrying a load like
human beings in some sense our design
for a load and the heavier the load the
better it's it's one of the things that
gives you you know there's this this
proclivity among psychologists to
attempt to facilitate self-esteem which
is a word I don't care much for I think
that self-respect is a much better term
and I think you develop self-respect by
carrying a responsibility I feel very
lucky to be born in this country I think
it's essentially a decent country does
follow a lot of what happens in the
United States I'll get to that in a
moment but I was talking to some welfare
workers police Salvation Army yesterday
saying to me they think society is
becoming and and particularly the
younger the age group we're talking is
becoming more aggressive more cynical
more angry do you agree with that and if
so why well I don't think the statistics
bear that out because what we've seen
over all over the last especially the
last 20 years is a remarkable decline in
violent crime I do think that there
might be an epidemic more of aimlessness
and and and depression and anxiety that
sort of thing
and I think that that's partly because
the case for growing up is not made well
and and and because we're also so
cynical about our own societies you know
I was in Amsterdam month ago talking to
a group of well-placed intellectuals
they're all friends of Theo van Gogh who
was who was killed in in in Amsterdam
about 15 years ago was stabbed and there
they said that embarrassment about the
Dutch culture is rampant in their
society and I that just makes my jaw
drop because I go to Holland and I think
my god this is such an amazing place
these people they scrape this country
out of the bottom of the ocean they
built dikes to hold back the waves it's
it's free it's it's liberal it's it's
compassionate its orderly it's beautiful
if there's lares but they're embarrassed
by it because of its tyrannical
patriarchal nature it's like well who
are you comparing it to it's like what
are we comparing our societies to where
do you want to live it on on the planet
or in time anywhere but in the West not
if you have any sense
you think you've sort of been described
as a warrior against political
correctness is that fit yeah tell me
about this in our national carrier
Qantas got some attention early this
week nice thing about this I knew you
were coming in and
taking advice from a diversity group
that's that's a bad idea
and I wanted to ban words like guys and
chairmen husband and wife replaceable
replace words like mankind and chairman
what's your reaction to that
I think that it would be better if
people tried to solve some real problems
instead of playing these idiot diversity
games I think that everyone who plays
identity politics whether they play it
on the right or the left is going to pay
for it in ways they can hardly imagine
it's a very counterproductive way of
dividing up the world it's an it's
impossible to come to a peaceful
solution in the identity politics
universe even the identity politics
types themselves they've run into this
problem they call intersectionality
right so ok so you classify people by
race and by sex let's say so and and
seek for equity along those dimensions
but then well what about the
intersection between those dimensions so
you you have enough ethnic minorities in
your in your organization let's say you
match by population which is an oldish
way of doing it but you do that and
maybe you're matched by sex but then
what about the intersection between race
and sex well then what about the rail
intersection between race sex ethnicity
then you could add social class to that
then you could add social proclivity
then you could add attractiveness
there's never-ending way of dividing
people up into groups and you can't
equalize across all those ways it's just
technically not possible do you think
people need to make a stand on issues
like this and when an airline like
Qantas makes these decisions do they
need to stand against it do they need to
boycott it and to do that sort of thing
I think they need to understand it at a
deeper level it's like we have to decide
if we're going to divide people up if we
think that dividing people up primarily
by their group identity is a good idea
and it's not it's a bad idea it will
lead to an enhancement of our tribal
proclivities and I don't think that if
you're a an advocate of peace that you
would push and advocate for ours further
division into tribal entities it's a
it's not wise
is this transient when we move through
this we'll see it's been not transient
in the past it's caused tremendous
troubles in the past this is another
reason why I'm not a fan of the radical
leftists so the the radical left
ideologies were were murderous in their
expression throughout the 20th century I
mentioned earlier this country follows a
lot of the US trends good and bad we're
a little bit behind but it can be
fashioned well what do we need to be
alert to what do we need to be aware of
what we need to avoid we need to we need
to be alert to the benefits of the
societies that we now inhabit we need to
be grateful for their existence and and
note very carefully the unlikelihood of
their continued success no I don't
understand how we managed it in the West
we have societies where the default
assumption between human beings is trust
I do not understand how we manage that
because there's so many ways that you
can be betrayed by someone especially if
you don't know them how do you set up a
society where the typical interaction
between strangers is straight oh how
many societies in the world are like
that like 30 40 something like that how
did that ever happen we don't know and
it's an ongoing miracle and we should do
everything we can not to disrupt it
because the alternative to that generous
trust that courageous trust which is
unbelievably productive is ruled by thug
and that's the rule in most of the world
such optimism will not for the future I
think we're in a time of extreme chaos
things could go unbelievably well if we
were careful there's so many good things
going on in the world right now they're
almost miraculous so for example between
the year 2000 and 2012 the level of
absolute poverty in the world was cut by
50%
that was the fastest rate of improvement
by a large margin in human history it
was three years faster than the most
optimistic projections had suggested
there's hundreds of thousands of people
a week now being being pulled into the
electrical power grid almost everyone
has access to almost infinite
computational power and all the
educational resources that go along with
that we're wiping out most transmissible
diseases the
dis growing economies in the world are
in sub-saharan Africa like there are a
lot of things
there's no starvation in China there's a
huge middle class in China and India
these things are absolutely miraculous
so and and god only knows what we could
accomplish if we got our act together in
the next 20 years you know the sky's the
limit so but we're playing very foolish
games in the West and we could bring the
house down around us so we'll see thank
you so much for coming in good luck with
the burden oh thanks very much for the
invitation and for the interview Jordan
B Peterson 12 rules for life an antidote
to chaos